like one example of the things i did is
i
just like actually started really um
listening to our um
audiobooks and podcasts much more like
just this year i basically
kind of discovered that the podcast
space is real for the first time i guess
like before that you know there would be
things that i would get interviewed for
but yeah i
yeah i was not really kind of like
mentally incorporated
i did not meant to incorporate this um
idea that like podcast r thing that you
can go listen to and this year i did
like i you know my
friend uh um carl lafourche one of the
the optimism people
uh recommended hardcore history to me
and so i went ahead and just listened to
all the hardcore histories
uh but then after that like listen to
like 10 lux friedmans and a bunch of
others says
and after that i also got into um audio
books
um oh i listened to the entire um
the rise and fall of the third reich the
whole thing 45 hours that that was
fascinating so what else let me ask
about that because dan is going to love
hearing this i'm going to
tell him do you have uh do you have a
period of history
whether it's dan or in general that you
draw for your own life like kind of
thinking about the world about human
nature that you go to
is it world war ii is it uh wrath of the
khans the
in genghis khan is it some other more
ancient history
is it world war one is there something
that kind of echoes with you
in the voice of dan or or anyone else
that you connect to
i feel like the 1930s and 40s are
fascinating because they force you to
like really grapple with uh
the question of like you know where does
evil come from right like the sort of
mental
puzzle that i've always had in my head
is like
on the one hand um you know things like
the holocaust happened
but on the other hand if you just go and
like have a coffee with
with people then like a hundred times
out of a hundred everyone just seems so
nice
yeah yeah so yeah exactly yeah like how
do you
kind of reconcile the macro in the micro
there right
and that's the sort of thing that's very
difficult
if you don't have um
a lot of i guess the right kind of
personal experience like especially if
your personal experience starts off
being sheltered like it was for me right
like i
you know the st i know the stereotype is
that the nerds get bullied in school but
like actually for me
in my school experience was just being
treated with kindness by everyone yeah
and so that definitely made it harder to
understand things
i remember actually being pretty
blindsided when i started ethereum and
then
within six months there started being
fights over like who would get more
shares if
ethereum turned out to be a company and
then i suggested we should just make it
be a nonprofit and somehow that ended up
upsetting people
um so
so the fascinating thing for me is that
like i've been you know
obviously reading and listening to the
history and then at the same time just
like
observing things happening in the crypto
space
and so one of my interesting or um
like mental intuitions that i've gotten
is that i think
like most evil doesn't come out of greed
it comes out of fear
and like one example
of this in ethereum lands right is um
like i think the part of ethereum
history where i thought that the
ethereum community was at its lowest and
even when i personally was at my lowest
um if you go back to the dow fork in
2016 right
so you know the dow hack happens and
then we made this controversial decision
to change the ethereum protocol
uh and we
um you know then there was that ethereum
classic split
and as soon as that ethereum classic
split um
happened you know there was like a lot
of anger everywhere and
uh there started there started
especially being anger when
the price of etc started like taking up
right so this was the time when
ether started off being 13 dollars in an
ethereum classic started at zero but
then
suddenly there was this one day when
like eath dropped to 12.5
etc went up to 0.5 and then they dropped
more
and people were saying things like um
you know oh
this whole thing ethereum classic is
just a like a psyop by
you know the bitcoin community and just
the wealthy bitcoiners trying to destroy
ethereum
and like in the back of my mind i knew
that that wasn't entirely true
like there were definitely were
bitcoiners but at the same time like i
think
blaming political like internal disa or
blaming disagreements on foreign
interference right like this is the sort
of thing that you know like
countries governments do all the time
like it's
a very convenient excuse right because
it allows you to just like
blame these things that are happening on
the foreigners and
avoid like actually grappling with the
facts that like well no actually you
have people in your very own community
who just
disagree with you and have a different
belief and
i think you know i feel like the
ethereum community like during that time
did not do a very good job of grappling
with that and i feel like like i during
that time
did not do a very good job of grappling
with that and so
there was a lot of like blaming the
bitcoiners there were also even a lot of
people
calling for us to use trademark one like
basically sue
exchanges and like try to prevent them
from listing ethereum classic
and like to me that was very unethical
right like this uh using
like basically using the government as a
weapon
to uh try to attack the other
cryptocurrency and like destroy it as
like
goes completely against them you know
the ideals of freedom and you know like
things that at least
in theory we're supposed to stand for um
but
you know like in that particular time
like basically
what was happening was that you know the
etc price was rising and at the same
time the th price was dropping in
lockstep
and it really and there are a lot of
bitcoin people basically saying this is
the end of ethereum and i think a lot of
people really were afraid that
ethereum would be just like completely
destroyed as a result of this
and so like that's where the anger came
from exactly
that's yeah exactly it came from the
fear and like that's what
i like allowed people to rationalize
like in
abandonment of principles that i think
they would not have um
accepted in other circumstances and
i i definitely like to to some extent
played along with this myself right and
i do definitely regret that to some
extent uh well and i
i definitely regret like the the
excesses completely
um but so that and then
obviously you know bitcoin block size
war similar sort of stuff happened uh
so like that that
insight was interesting um because like
it does mentally make a lot of sense
right like when you're actually
afraid that you know unless you act in
some way that you know your entire world
is going to collapse like it's much
easier to just
rationalize you know forgetting your
principles and doing whatever you have
to to just
save the specific thing that you care
about it feels like the right thing to
do
the the brave thing to do is in the face
of fear
to still have compassion to still have
love
as opposed to hate so the the darkest
moments
the the toughest moments of human
history are those where fear
is everywhere and despite that
like the way to get out of that
is uh is through love not giving into
the fear and
again that's the lesson that you draw
from all those moments of history
yeah well i i like you have in terms of
those coffee and the kindness that
people have
it does seem that everybody has the
capacity for evil and everybody has the
capacity for love and you just have to
create
mechanisms and incentives that uh
prioritize the latter over the former
vitalik
you're one of the most interesting
people i've gotten a chance to talk to
um thank you so much for talking i i
hope we get a chance to talk again
i hope but i can at least be at some
small part this would be awesome on a
podcast with you and dan carlin
that would be an awesome conversation uh
like thank you so much for doing
so much incredible technical innovation
that inspires the computer scientists uh
the economist
inspires the world and what technology
can do and now with longevity
i do hope we live a very long time
and uh play diablo to make
that long time fun thank you so much for
talking today thank you to alex this was
great
you